hey guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we're doing another
unbiased blind camera comparison with a
brand new s21 ultra against
the iphone 12 pro max go ahead and get
out your pen and paper or your notes app
it's a lot more fun if you play along
and i just want to say that
looking at these images i went out and
shot them this is going to be an
absolute tough comparison
but there are a few shocking images that
i really wasn't expecting so
let's go ahead and jump right in you
guys see this first one
what do you think i mean to me it's
obviously the one on the left i really
hate when the white balance
gets so cool like the one on the right i
just it really bugs me
i don't know if i'm just crazy but it
seems like there might be a little bit
more
detail on the right but also the white
balance is really really messed up and
that might just be like some sharpening
but i'm also going with the left
and the results are s21 ultra first
points
goes to that next shot right here we
have theo chillin
uh i think i'm going with the one on the
right i feel like there's a lot more
detail
yeah if you look very closely you can
tell that on the left um all of his fur
is very kind of like smeared and soft
12 pro max so one for each
and we have a macro shot here whoa
so this is the closest each camera can
get
uh i think i'm definitely going with the
one on the right
there's so much more detail and you can
get a lot closer
yeah the difference in detail is just
insane i think the uh
depth of field on the left is just too
overkill
so you don't really get much detail
there it's kind of like blurred out so
yeah one on the right again
s21 ultra and i will say that
with the s20 shots like this look
terrible
and now they have somehow fixed it and
with that difference that we're noticing
here
i do want to mention that we're gonna
redo this blind camera test with the new
s21 ultra the note 20 ultra
and the s20 ultra that's three
generations of samsung
phones to see what differences we have
there so definitely subscribe
so you see that and here is the next one
and i have to say that i took
like five shots each time because i
wanted to make sure that the results
were
accurate and what you see is accurate
basically obviously the right i mean
yeah of course the left one looks really
bad
all right that is the 12 pro max and it
just has a faster shutter speed with
that
huge sensor and both are big it takes
longer for it to read it out so
this was just a natural shot that i want
to get and you can't grab it and here we
have a nice beautiful colorful piece
uh i kind of like the brightness of the
right one but i feel like you can see a
lot more
detail on the left one i think i'm gonna
go with the right personally because i
like the extra depth of field so the
background looks a little bit more
blurred out so it kind of stands out s21
and now it's time to head outside on a
foggy morning
so with this one the same issue came up
where the one on the right looks too
blue
but if you do look closely the one on
the left is just kind of soft it's just
not as detailed if you look very close
so personally i would rather go with the
right one and maybe fix the white
balance a little bit because you can't
fix that loss of detail
yeah i completely agree 12 pro max and
it's weird that once again it got the
white balance off
and there's a lot of details that are
crushed right here usually it's samsung
that gets white balance off
and they crush the blacks all right so
now we have a selfie one of the few
selfies that are in here
these are very very different the one on
the right there's a lot of added
contrast but honestly i like that
because on the one on the left you look
old hey my hair's not great
you do not look like that in real life
yes i look a lot a lot more
attractive there so for me i think
there's a little bit too much
not too much contrast but it's a little
bit crushed on the right that's what i
don't like about it and it's a little
bit too
cool but the one on the left is
extremely flat
and it has much less detail it's much
more soft and it's just too flat so
the one on the right for sure s21 ultra
it's interesting that's more
contrast here when in the previous
photos it had less contrast so
now we got a nice portrait shot at the
park i like the one on the left more
because the right one
there is like not as much detail on
her shoes and then with the portrait
mode it messed up over here
yeah it is a good point for me i'm
choosing the left also
but because the details are not crushed
on the right you can see like the jeans
are totally black like in this area very
crushed
and if you look closely there's more
detail especially like in the hair if
you look up close
more detail in the hair so s21 ultra
alright so now we have an
ultra wide shot right easy right
wow yeah that's easy first of all a lot
of crushing dynamic range you could
actually see blue in the sky
right you got much more detail
everywhere the one on the left
everything looks like
i don't know if that's orange or green
it's all like one color
this is why we're doing uh the unbiased
style
because i like the one on the left and i
actually vote
i saw the images but i chose which ones
i like best and i know my results out of
all these images so it's going to be
interesting to see what they get
and also what you guys get so you guys
can comment below
that is the s21 ultra once again all
right
so landscape shot here let's see if that
108 megapixels
helps man this one is really really
tough it's almost identical
yeah it's so close but i think i'm going
with the right because of the extra
detail i can just see
everything's more sharp it does have
more contrast but man it's it's tough
uh i'm thinking the opposite the only
thing that i can notice difference wise
is that there's a lot of crushing so i
see
less detail because of that yeah because
of that maybe over sharpened i don't
know so you're going left
yeah i'm going to stop all right s21 and
12 pro max
what no way well i mean yeah
i mean you have the crazy zoom lens this
is so
no way wow is this 100x
no no this is uh this is 10x no
this is 10x the iphone does have the new
two and a half times
um zoom lens and has deep fusion which
isn't work
it's working here look you could see
like the little trees way
back there this is all like a big foot
yeah not only all the details incredible
you also get
color look at that this is just gone so
obviously that is the s21
ultra and then now we have another
portrait shot of emily here and this is
a
really really tough one with this one i
really like the one on the left because
it has a more natural kind of
blur roll-off where it kind of like goes
deeper
the only issue is that right above her
head there's no blur at all in that
section which
is really really annoying whereas this
one does a little bit better at that
but the detail is just so much better on
the left i don't know it's just so tough
for me this is really hard i think i do
like the one on the left more
even though there's like some crushed
detail but yeah like up here this just
looks crazy there's so much blur here
and there's
nothing there and also behind the
pigtail right there
yeah but then over here there's like a
lot of her hair that's kind of too
blurred so you
lose a lot of detail there's some
weirdness s21 ultra so they're both good
at different things this image looks
like a dslr
it's sharp it's detailed the color looks
great this isn't detailed the color
doesn't look good
but the blur is much better we got
another
shot here another zoom so this shot um i
was thinking about how much zoom shots
did i put in there's not too many
uh but this was a natural shot they
climbed up on top of this hillside i
want to take a photo of him so i can see
him
i would take a shot like this normally
day to day life so
yeah you choose one why do you have to
ask they look scary
the one on the right looks way better it
is the s21
ultra okay and we have a shot of elon
here
chillin this one is very very close but
if you look closely
there's more detail on the left where
you could see like this texture
in the wood and everything and yeah i'm
definitely going with that
left one for sure um i disagree i like
the one on the right
i don't know exactly why i just do just
like it yep
i agree 12 pro max s21
ultra so the iphone colors are always a
bit off
still the samsung colors are great but
the iphone
you look at the hand slightly this looks
like a dslr photo as far as the blur
this looks like a dslr photo as far as
the detail that it's able to capture
all right so ultra right over here
interesting uh yeah i mean right one
just for the details sake i'm going with
the right it's more ultra wide
but because of the detail i'd rather go
with that one i think i'd rather go with
the left one the right one looks sort of
like distorted in an unnatural way where
the left one looks more
natural that's the point it's hard it is
really hard and this is crazy how little
distortion there is
while it's being so wide so you guys
chose yeah
12 pro max and s21 ultra so far it
is a close battle and i'm curious what
you guys
are gonna have to say and the next one
bam
what what happened this is not
a joke this is not a joke i gotta tell
you guys
i shot this three or four times yeah to
give this camera a chance
this is what you get no way how did that
happen
that's garbage sorry it is garbage yeah
it's a left for sure what is it
all right s21 ultra and i have to say
this is the brand new three times
optical camera no
using night mode versus uh
apple's two and a half times camera so
it's fair here 10 megapixel versus 12.
i did this like i said three four times
this is a result every time
and it's what happened the software is
just
trash and we have another nighttime shot
uh but this is using
standard cameras i'm gonna go with the
one on the left i mean um it brightened
it up a little bit more i can see more
detail in the sign
and in the uh table everywhere i like
that one better
yep same 12 pro max trying to catch up
yeah is it trying to catch up now
all right next one we have a portrait
shot
at night man this one is extremely tough
they're just so close i say i don't like
either one really
they both look terrible but honestly i
kind of like the one on the right more
because
i kind of like the look of the bokeh
better and the one on the left just
looks over
sharpened like sharpening to the extreme
i don't know
and you know what i don't even remember
which one of these is which yeah
angelica do you um i disagree i think
the one on the left looks better
just because there's like a such a big
lack of detail
that the over sharpening i think
actually helps kind of makes up for it i
don't know and i will say
i don't remember which one is which but
the iphone is using the two and a half
times lens
where the samsung even though it has
that three times optical zoom lens
it still crops in digitally on the main
sensor for this shot and then
but the results look very similar s21 on
the left getting close
and i said it's a close one and then
what
i have to do is i have to do a moonshot
after you did that one
whoa that's so good is this this is 100x
yeah
uh this is i don't know i just zoomed in
as much as i could to fill the frame
what um and then the iphone i had to
digitally zoom in a little bit more
because it does 12 and a half
so this might be like 30 years noise
it was i will say that the iphone the
moon looks a lot better than last time
and a half it's fake it's cgi yeah
obviously i think i know which one you
guys would want you can actually take
moonshots with this this is an
incredible and it wasn't that hard
wow i the iphone actually took like
three or four times
because i thought my focus was going off
this was just done
honestly this is one thing that would
make me want to switch just for this for
moonshots just for moonshots
s21 ultra that one is very obvious
killer
and here you go this is another zoom
shot yeah i'm going with oh man that's
kind of
tough i'm going with the right i think i
see more detail and
the lights aren't as blown out uh if i
had to choose one to be my phone i think
i'd go with the right
s21 ultra killing it next one
this is uh nighttime it was super dark
okay
yeah and it's a nighttime portrait
selfie portrait left for sure
a lot better destroyed it absolutely s21
man ultra so floating heads it's
that's incredible that's true actually i
was looking at the vases look at the
my jacket yeah you're right all right
next one we have this nighttime scene
with lots of bright highlights and then
lots of shadow areas as well
that's close these guys have been
looking at this photo for
i don't know a couple minutes now and
that shows that both of these are good
great cameras
it's so tight you guys gotta choose one
i don't know i'm gonna go with the
point i'm gonna go with the right two
all right s21
ultra so both both are awesome shots
it was really dang dark though super
dark i will say that
all right we got one more this one is an
ultra wide
shot okay i like the one on the right
yeah
the one on the right like uh the left
one's super flat everything's all flat
nothing pops but the one on the right
those lights pop um compared to like
those trees in the back
stand out more details yeah good points
um i don't remember which one is which
s21 ultra wow all right i can't stop it
and we got a clock tower yeah
you guys saw the wide shot here's the
tighter shot left wow
um this is for me it was kind of tough
yeah this one's tough because you have
more detail and like all this kind of
stuff
right but everything's like so flat
and you have like annoying all this
noise too whereas this is more soft
it's not as detailed but at least it
stands out man this is
super positives about this than there
are about that i don't know i mean
if your goal was to see what time it is
it's this one
i guess uh i don't know man i'll i'll go
left i don't know
s21 ultra i have to say though this is a
two and a half time
zoom shot with deep fusion so when it
starts getting dark
i mean they process it differently but i
thought it was going to be a much bigger
difference
now we have a shot of emily and then
there is also anoa
hiding in the background
and i would say like i said it's super
dark so like the snow to my eyes looked
almost blown out
and that was like i could barely see
noah so both these cameras did a killer
job
at capturing this i guess it's
preference what you like i mean i'm
going with the right i see more detail
everywhere more detail everywhere so
right
i like that yeah right 12 pro max oops i
guess i got a glitch in here
that is the 12 pro max though and now we
have a street scene here and
both of these just did a killer job i
would say it's not perfect
but i was surprised i know what i'm
going for okay yep
that was quick i'm going for the left
right
all right s21 ultra 12 pro max these
signs
were bright and here was super dark
you can see so much of the detail in it
and then that and if you want you can
just bring it up and it'll be a little
brighter a lot more detail here even
though it's 12 megapixel instead of
108. i just don't like those reflections
yeah
yeah yeah and i actually before you guys
need to see this is the issue with the
iphones
all those little dots look how clean
yeah there's nothing here and this was a
really tough scene
super bright and colorful inside pretty
much pitch black outside
why'd you do all these tough ones man i
don't know honestly i did not expect
this to be this close i don't think
we've ever had a test that was disc
this close when they're both making
images so similar and doing a great job
at it
i feel like i can see a lot more detail
on the left this one's tough i think i'm
gonna go with the
left because i guess like less details
crushed
like near the bottom and then like i
think the colors pop a little bit more
on the inside and the detail is good too
even imbalanced yeah you are right 12
pro max
i actually didn't remember which one is
which this is the last one okay
ultra wide shot yeah i mean here i'm
going for the right
for sure just because of the contrast
between the lights
and the sky this guy's all black we're
here it's kind of like faded
and you know yeah i mean you kind of see
the clouds and stuff right see trees
you see trees and clouds so it's it's
capturing that
yeah but it's not the better image in my
opinion it's not as detailed yeah
so 12 pro max i think the last few have
been the 12 pro max
so maybe it's just maybe it's more
mature night time photos but
that's interesting because this is a new
sensor here this one they've used since
the s20
it's just software differences so all
right guys so
pause for a second guys go count up what
you
chose we want you guys to comment first
before hearing
our hearing what they got and then
hearing what i got in my test so
go ahead and pause guys did you choose
yours
all right yes we got them okay angelica
what did you get
i got 17. you want to show it off to
them or the s21 ultra and 11 for the
12 pro max okay ambidi 18 for the s21
ultra and
10 for the 12 pro wow and you guys can
make sure make sure you commented below
and this is why we do
unbuy style it's interesting and we
don't know which is which now me
personally i disagreed with these guys
a few times i i just personally like a
little more contrast on some of the
shots and that's why we have preference
i got 14 and 14 really when i was going
through
no way and it was i did not do that on
purpose but i also didn't do it unbiased
like you guys did
so it looks like yes the s21 ultra
is the better camera and samsung has
done a fantastic
job it's the king it is the king not
only in that zoom
i think the one thing is that 3x optical
i don't know what it's even there for
marketing i don't know but the zoom is
awesome and a lot of the shots just look
natural and great
like the iphones used to look i guess so
there you guys go
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button you guys don't want to miss out
the comparison between
this s21 the note 20 and the s20 that's
going to be
very interesting and check out one of
those great videos over there this has
been max
angelica and vadim and we'll see you
guys in the next video
[Music]